All right.
Now it's time to try coding the Gaussian
elimination algorithm ourselves.
To start us off,
I've written the template for
a python module that represents
a system of linear equations.
I'll give a brief overview of it here.
It is also available for download in the
downloadable section in this segment and
the rest of the lesson.
We can initialize a new
linear system object
by providing a list of plain objects.
The initializer make sure all of our
planes live in the same dimension.
So we can't mix planes living
in three-dimensional space
with objects such as lines
living in two-dimensional space.
There are currently
three empty functions.
Swap rows, multiply coefficient and
row, and add multiple times row to row.
These will be the focus of the first
stage of building the Gaussian
elimination algorithm.
There's also a function which
obtains which term of each equation
is the first non-zero term.
This will be useful for finding
the pivot variables in each equation.
Note that the terms are zero
index instead of one indexed.
Though we shouldn't need
to worry about that.
Since we won't be directly manipulating
the indices of the lists that make up
the system.
We also have some utility
functions available to us.
The LEN function returns how
many planes are in the system.
In other words,
how many equations are in the system.
We can also use subscript notation
to access a particular plane, or
equation in the system.
As demonstrated in the example
code at the bottom of the module.
There's also an str
method that let's us print
a pretty version of
the system of equations.
Finally, in the module I've included
a simple extension of the decimal class.
It gives us the ability to quickly
check whether a decimal object
is within a given tolerance to zero.
In this case, the default
tolerance is ten to the minus ten.
If you execute the test code given
at the bottom of the module.
You can see the output of these
functions on an example system.
Feel free to take some time to
play around with this example.
For instance, by changing
the coefficients to get a feel for
the functionality of
the linear system class.